indeed I have a special guest I have Yan
who just finished his game against Leon
Ronan the game finished in a draw three
draws so far Yan how is it going for
you the
tournament hard to say so like in the
first round it wasn't
really um a full you know a full game
and yesterday was like a long game and
yeah with h quite an unfortunate final
moves uh yeah but today yeah I think I
misplayed opening very very badly so I
mixed up some ideas and
um I think at some point I thought like
it's like it's not like a Thanksgiving
day for me like it's like giveaway day
so like my position was like I mean at
least optically going worse and worse
extremely extremely fast yeah so it
didn't feel that way from outside can
you explain exactly the moments when you
thought the position was well first of
all U yeah you can even play like this
yeah like cded but this is
um not like anything quite is really
trying to achieve any advantage just
more like um trying to deviate from
uh some known lines so it's like that
similar position is In N then is Bishop
was on B4 well not not such a big
difference for black so I can do the
same but uh what I did was I tried to
play this line with Bishop A6 which is I
mean it makes sense but um I think the
thing I mixed up a little that there is
a very similar position in Bishop D2 A3
line uh but then the bishop is on D2 D5
is not under attack so the difference is
like Knight D6 uh Knight E5 so here
probably I should played Queen C8 or
something anyway yeah like to make a
response sensible move like Queen goes
to E6 very solid yeah but okay of course
my idea was to play C5 but then Knight
C6 Queen D7 let's say um takes takes
here and the pawn on D5 is hanging so
probably this
was also not that bad but you know if
you take with the the Knight mhm right
unfortunately is not forced to take on
to capture on D5 yeah so then I get some
nice compensation but instead just
played for isoled Pawn like something B3
knight2 Bishop B2 and looks like I'm not
I'm simply not in time to deal with it
so it's like slightly worse for a very
very uh long uh long term so here well
that's why I played Bishop D6 but yeah
clearly I I lost the trace I like Anyway
the position is very solid so probably
it is but after Queen E2 I mean it's
suddenly quite unpleasant to choose
between like Queen C8 and Knight B8 like
both moves are not great uh there would
be a nice move Knight C5 but
unfortunately here Knight C6 Queen D7
takes takes and Knight okay Knight to5
at least so Queen A6 so it doesn't
work uh so I'm pretty much forced uh to
go I mean like Queen C8 was also a move
but um I think the problem is the same
like E4 and my pieces are uh quite
poorly coordinated so okay I have this
Knight C5 trick at
in in in this moment but yeah it's not
that doesn't look great either so
E4 well here I had a choice uh actually
I could also play like Bishop
E5 maybe it would be I mean even more
passive than what I got what I got but U
maybe
slightly slightly more solid because I I
I'm not getting my weak Pawn on D5 but I
was somehow not concerned and I think I
was wrong so here like 9 D5 is principal
Bishop E5 Queen
E4 so yeah so C6 is probably the only
move because if I play let's say Bishop
D6 there is I mean I have very very
slight compensation here so for example
if Knight F6 Queen F6 queen8 Knight C6 I
think I'm doing more or less fine uh but
the problem that he can go some Knight
B6 well a lot of different moves yeah
also like Knight B6 a lot of moves here
works so yeah yeah KN B6 uh as well yeah
crazy yeah but yeah quite you know quite
logical so okay when you play like
Knight A6 B8 and back yeah back and
forth it's not so good so C6 this was
pretty much forced so here taking with
the queen was quite principal but then
he takes takes Rook D1 Knight C6 Rook D5
Rook d8 uh takes and Bishop F4 so this
somehow I believe should be playable for
black but I mean still it's like a pawn
so not so great maybe I call the draw
here I mean most likely black draws this
but um because of the active Rook yeah
like
and Pa on E5 is also a weakness so but I
wasn't so sure so I decided to play like
cd5 Queen G4 well Queen G4 I'm not sure
uh he had so many nice moves here like
played positionally in different way so
maybe Queen E2 was the move also but
okay Queen G4 is principal and here uh
well I was choosing between Queen C8 and
queen D7 I'm not sure so this leads to
pretty much similar positions like Rook
C2 takes Knight C6 but here he can just
I don't know like play like F4 or maybe
H3 or or B3 like a lot of moves and I'm
not sure I'm getting full compensation
as well yeah so I was also concerned so
I decided to play Queen D7 but in fact
this position is very
dangerous so we exchange it F4 I'm not
sure so left suggested something like F6
uh A6 Knight C5 F5 and then D4 and then
slowly like play Rook d8 Rook D5 and
then G6 which maybe makes sense but was
not obvious for me like at all like
letting this Pawn on6 survive which
probably will be there forever looks
dangerous also yeah so Knight
C5 Rook D1 maybe here I should have
tried other Rook to d8 uh but wasn't
obvious to me at that at that point so
somehow I felt like after Bishop E3 G6
if he goes G4 then there is some mess
and maybe I'm um should be doing fine I
was way more concerned about some calm C
move like Rook a C1 Knight A6 let's say
G3 and yeah the type of position would
hardly ever change and he just slowly
improves like comes with his King to A3
then okay H3 G4 so probably I should
hold it with some precise play but this
like this is very unpleasant end game
very unpleasant so like even like play
D4 Bishop F2 Rook a C8 like I don't know
King
G2 H I don't know let's say F6 takes
King F7 King F3 and so on probably yeah
like slowly white trying to improve
but I mean this is nothing but but
Pleasant for black but here surprisingly
I five D4 uh so here I thought like I
mean maybe just lost after Bishop H6
and7 F6 96 rookie C1 so because of like
the back rank problem so my king is
basically trapped but maybe it's not not
as bad as it seems yeah like I play
something like Rook a C8 and um maybe I
play G5 and D3 so okay at least uh this
didn't really depend on me already so I
did everything I could to to get into
trouble but the rest was yeah Prett
pretty random I would say yeah and just
exchange and here here the only only
thing that after E7 you have to play
Rook D2 too uh otherwise I think it's
very very dangerous but yeah this is
enough so after King
F1 I I don't think I had anything better
than than what I achieved exactly so the
game finished in a draw I'm sure that
you noticed that one board was empty
todaya withdraw officially from the
tournament so what do you think about it
and have you ever actually had similar
experience withdrawing from the
event uh you know I wanted this I wanted
to do this so many times you know
probably even yesterday I wanted the
same like so uh I know you didn't feel
well also yes yeah well uh also but uh
yeah I guess it should be something
serious so I hope like everything will
be well with Yang shishov so but yeah
maybe this tournament is a little bit
you know doomed so last year it was like
like some another reason but already
after three rounds uh one player uh
decided to withdraw this year is a
different story but already after first
round
yeah so yeah happens yeah yes exactly
thank you so muchan all the best of luck
in the last rounds please stay with us
till the end thank you thank you thank
you Anastasia well there you heard it
himself that